I want to talk a little bit today about
the entire let's open on Easter delusion
that Donald Trump wanted with packed
churches which now is not going to
happen as medical doctors have explained
to Trump we at least have to stay
shutdown until April 30th and so Donald
Trump obviously he wants to reopen
things as soon as possible he wants to
let it rip as soon as possible he thinks
it will be good for approval and good
for the economy and good for his
reelection and Trump specifically was
looking at Easter which again has now
been cancelled with this narrative of
packed churches on Easter because there
is an element of Trump wanting to be
seen in a Jesus like way he has a sort
of God complex of Trump as the
resurrector of the United States on
Easter Trump equates this idea of him
miraculously reopening the country on
Easter as a sort of second coming of
Christ of a sort Trump imagines this
scenario where were shuttered and closed
down we are in a winter literally and
metaphorically and then it becomes
spring as it now is and he will take the
country back to being open on Easter
Christians will fill churches and pray
not just to God but to Trump deifying
him as a pseudo godlike figure that
entire rebirth story is a very popular
story with Christians and Easter
perfectly Brent blends that resurrection
of Jesus with the resurrection of the
United States now it's not happening
clearly it didn't make sense from the
get-go and doctors have convinced Trump
of that but the level of delusion and
God complex that the president has
combined with his complete inability to
ever take responsibility for anything
it's not just sad it's not just tragic
it's actually a danger and you know with
everything that we know the virus takes
ten to fourteen days between incubation
and until symptoms start if Trump did
this and we were reaching the peak right
around Easter as we are expected to do
we might have actually seen a slight
decline if Trump did this for a few days
which would have fueled his bully
that he did the right thing but then
around April 25th we would have seen a
rapid up shot in the number of new cases
and deaths because of the delayed effect
of the contagion so it's a very good
thing that Trump decided not to do this
but the degree to which Trump is
starring in a reality show of his own
making where he increasingly casts
himself as a deity of sorts while
science and rationality crumble around
Trump is very very scary I started
searching around the internet to see
whether my suspicions about this god
complex were right and and in fact you
already had evangelicals posting on
Reddit and on Twitter stuff like Trump
is going to raise the nation from the
dead on Easter just like Jesus rose from
the dead here's a reminder by the way of
Trump talking about why he wanted Easter
and the packed churches by the way but
order line is never going to be like
being there so I think Easter Sunday and
you'll have packed churches all over our
country I think would be a beautiful
time and it's just about the timeline
that I think is right it gives us more
chance to work on what we're doing and
I'm not sure that's going to be the day
but I would love to aim it right at
Easter Sunday so we're open for church
service and services generally on Easter
Sunday that would be a beautiful thing
so we would all have suffered greatly
because of that god complex that Trump
presents there Trump again imagining
parishioners thanking Trump nationwide
of course in advance of what would have
been an even more escalating more
quickly escalating caseload and death
toll and it's a form of the Christian
dominionism that we've been talking
about on our show for a long time it's
embodied by Trump who again I don't
believe for a second is religious
personally but he successfully tricked
many of his followers into believing
that he is and meanwhile of course case
numbers have continued to explode
looking very ugly my hope is and I don't
know whether this will happen that by
the middle to end of this week we might
start to see a reduced growth factor
that doesn't mean new case numbers will
decrease in the net in the aggregate in
the raw numbers but maybe the growth
rate might decrease where I'm hoping
but we had 19,000 new cases on Saturday
confirmed of course many many more in
reality about 19,000 confirmed cases
yesterday on Sunday on Saturday we had
525 deaths
yesterday thankfully a decrease to only
a little under 300 deaths but questions
about whether those are really being
correctly tracked if someone dies of
respiratory distress
is it being counted as a corona virus
death or not and this is a sort of death
certificate thing that anthony foul she
actually spoke about during a recent
interview that's a very specific detail
it has all been going wrong Trump making
the right decision not to open on Easter
and Trump clearly being convinced by the
doctors around him that his god complex
wanting to be deified on Easter by
evangelical Christian followers packing
churches and praying not just to God but
also to Trump did not outweigh the fact
that we need to be shut down for an
additional 30 days 32 days from today
that's what we know as of now let me
know you're thinking about the 30 days
the the 32 days from now I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman we'll take a break
packed show today